après service après-vente j'écoute
j'ai mis un diable ok mais pourquoi
faire ton ferme où c'est l'hiver suédois
j'ai bien dit on au service après-vente
bonjour oui bonjour
ben voilà en cette période où la france
souffre je me devais de prendre la
parole pour dire à nos concitoyens
ça va je suis là je suis avec vous je
pense à vous et merci merci beaucoup à
vous à tous pardon pardon je suis qui je
suis qui mais je suis françois le
français fixé le mois prochain les
français bleu blanc rouge foncé les
français le bleu-blanc-rouge tous avec
moi
nantes ou sept morts
service après-vente bonjour mesdames et
messieurs bonjour et bienvenue un proxy
passe à cause qu'on aime pivot escargots
et vous avez gagné la coupe du monde on
dégage est que oui dans l'oreille aux
soins aux animaux un one of a kind of
the shit willy bensaid trop bon
apparement je ne sais pas ce que je
raconte que le bahreïn service
après-vente bonjour aux gros coups d'ici
non mais c'est moi messi que je trouve
un truc drôle dit ouais c'est trop
galerie à abc moi super kaunas super
kaunas
ah oui c'est moi ouais c'est trop
gonnery service après-vente bonjour oui
bonjour juste un petit mot sur le vaccin
non merci service après vente ou bonjour
j'ai mis des pierres pour quoi faire
pour faire nutr gmail service
après-vente bonjour toc toc toc qui est
là tout doux de doké d'où il faudrait
d'oublier pour y croire et faudrait doux
d'oublier maryse ses doudous angel ouais
c'est qu'en mangeant moins bien
sammis après-vente bonjour bonjour c'est
quoi votre prénom me nomme fadili en
chantier en chantier chantier jean
bloguin humoristes ok ça a dû sacrément
bon jour coucou mon chéri c'est tata
suzanne pop un ça va
bah ça va il coûte alors je te dire
depuis quand on a le droit de sortir
lassus contente a aussi jeté confinant
je vais te dire que ce hd confine c'est
quelqu'un qui les confine c'est ta ta ta
merde partout si tu vois ce que je veux
dire non non je m'en fout un coup ça va
ça présente bonjour oui bonjour agents
trop cher à jean trop cher la vie n'a
pas de prix pas le pays téléphone
téléphone jambes longues à l'humoriste
agente à quatre proches sert comment ça
va merci de ma vie n'a pas de prix je
vous entends pas elles sont fermées
service après-vente bonjour oui bonjour
à
apparemment vous avez ma voix
ah oui
et vous la mienne
on raccroche oui c'est préférable chain
préserver mon identité
au revoir monsieur service après-vente
bonjour bonjour
non je me disais le prochain premier
mais bon on va pas fêter la fête du
travail
avant on va fêter la fête du télétravail
[Musique]
elle est bonne au service après-vente
bonjour oui bonjour c'était juste pour
savoir si vous étiez au courant que
simon ajoutent 60 de lettres haut-mauco
vide ça donne le compte d'un virus a été
créé en laboratoire pour modifier les
équilibres mondiaux
c'est bizarre non c'est vrai que c'est
super bizarre et est ce que vous vous
êtes au courant que si on rajoute 16
lettre o qu'ovide ça donne je vais
raccrocher du conte service après-vente
bonjour la dis donc tu viens me fait au
soir et alors là non je ne peux pas
juger un rhume
c'est dommage on assigne soirée
mexicaine je peux te dire qu'il a eu à y
pinto service après-vente bonjour et
vous reconnaissez non c'est moi en
période de kobe qui vous dit ah ben tu
cours se fait pas la vise c'est moi
super kaunas c'est pourquoi on ne sait
pourquoi
hornus c'est moi mais tu qu'on ne fait
pas la bise
service après-vente bonjour oui pouchon
je vous appelle pour savoir si laurent
ournac a gardé contact avec adeline pour
mon incroyable fiancé
c'est une émission de télé réalité qui
date de 2006 madame oui et donc et donc
on s'en fout mais oui c'est vrai ben oui
je vous en prie oui ok ça chie service
après-vente bonjour j'ai mis un peu de
beurre julien bonnet de bain pour quoi
faire pour faire comme fred testot
dresse avait des émissions julien bonnet
de bain c'est bien monsieur merci j'ai
un vrai test au générique de l'offre et
testo a très bien l'asie les rigolos sa
remise à palente dangereux oui bonjour
vous me voyez très bien c'est bon mais
lunettes le marche parfaitement service
après-vente bonjour bonjour pour le rôti
de lotte au lard où il faut mettre ou le
bouquet de thym est fine et de petits de
dollars alors attendez je l'avais ça
c'est celle là voilà alors donc déjà
fois arroser les filets avec de l'huile
d'olive 1 voilà pour les laisser mariner
un petit peu avec du sel du poivre
rick est un et alors ensuite vous ai
goûté les filets voulait réunissiez
ensemble voilà cher contre cher et vous
enfermez le teint au mieux voilà au
milieu il faut enfermer le temps entre
les chiens oui oui et alors ensuite pour
finir on avoue garder les boules avec
les tranches de lard voilà pour former
un rôti simplement fou que ça donne
faut que ça parte faut que ça passe donc
c'est pas ça barde de moi bah deux mois
par deux mois où la bonne recette
au revoir au revoir